I'm glad I didn't give up because I
wouldn't have after 32 years in prison
the outside is an unfamiliar place it's
so space-aged now when Andrew Wilson
still can't quite believe he's free oh
you know I I haven't had movement like
this I haven't seen movement like this
you know you don't thirty-two years it's
being confined to a every day program we
spoke just hours after his release a
judge having thrown out his murder
conviction family members some of whom
he'd never met there for him what was
that moment like it scared me it scared
me
but it was a good moment it was a happy
moment for me you know because I I got a
chance to not just sit and talk to him
but I had a chance to to hug my my loved
one and you know tell him that I loved
Andrew Wilson was convicted of a killing
that took place here in South Central
Los Angeles in October 1984 a 21 year
old man called Christopher Hanson was
stabbed to death as he slept in his
truck here Andrew Wilson always said he
had nothing to do with that murder
prosecutors admitted key evidence about
what happened here had been withheld
from the jury
denying mr. Wilson a fair trial the
people who are responsible for you going
to prison do you feel angry towards them
how do I have time for that I don't have
time for that if I if I do that I'm
taking good energy and wasting it I can
be spending that energy on my family I
don't have time for that
when you're in prison for something you
didn't do
how do you how do you deal with how do
you deal with that and in prison for
such a long time for that you just do it
and you and you you keep your fight
going on you it's like anything else if
there's something that you want you
fight for and you never give up you know
what if you know you're innocent never
give up his shirt is a tribute to the
law school students who campaigned for
his release his next stop being with his
mother when she turns 97 in a few weeks
time I don't have titles waste being mad
or thinking of some negative I don't
have time his life is too shy Greg Milam
Sky News Los Angeles